put the phone away for 2 minutes put it
across the room or in another room sit
down pick a point on the wall and just
try and relax while maintaining visual
Focus for 120 seconds on a location you
can blink if you want to what you'll
find is it's incredibly boring and
agitating like most things you need to
focus on and have a hard time focusing
on just a little bit of focus training
for 2 3 minutes every once in a while
will teach you to recognize when you
have that impulse to get up and move
what you'll find is that it carries over
to a really terrific ability to read to
study to listen and you start to notice
those internal signals there's something
you need to do and you don't want to do
it or you can't focus chances are you
just haven't really taught your brain
how to focus so start with your visual
focus and then let your mental focus
follow that